- [Voiceover] Dear past me,
I know it's been awhile but it's
because I've been trying
to grow and get better.
And I know things are
hard for you right now,
no matter how hard to try,
you just can't seem to make Mom happy.
And I know Mom says some really
hurtful things to you sometimes
and you feel like you deserve it
and I know you get angry at yourself a lot
and you're frustrated
and you feel like you're worthless
so you tell yourself that all the time
but I promise you you're not worthless.
Don't forget that you
can always ask for help.
Even if it's just somebody to talk to.
You've been told that you should believe
and listen to everything your parents say
but nobody is perfect.
So sometimes they make mistakes
and sometimes they hurt themselves
and hurt you.
And all because they're trying to love you
but don't know how.
And I want you to know
that I still love Mom.
And I've come to terms
with the fact that she may
never understand the kind
of pain she's made me feel.
And I wish Mom would realize
that she deserves to love herself too.
But there's little I can do.
I'm not as close with her anymore
but that's okay 'cause some relationships
work better at a distance.
Even if you're born into it.
And it's gonna be hard but
it'll get better I promise
because in the end,
all you need to do is love yourself
and be kind to yourself.
Allow yourself to grow.
I want you to know that I love you
and you should love you too.
I know you're gonna do great.
(instrumental piano music)